Float on down.
We're going deep into the sewers to dig up
all the Easter eggs and references you might've
missed in It: Chapter Two.
Now is your last chance to turn back, because
there are plenty of spoilers and scares ahead.
Stephen King's stories are often connected
through their New England locations as well
as their monsters.
It takes place in Derry, Maine, and the book
often references the nearby town of Castle
Rock, where multiple works by King are set,
including his novella "The Body" and its movie
adaptation, Stand By Me.
These two stories are also connected through
their focus on friendship, childhood trauma,
and the end of innocence as groups of kids
are forced to confront dark forces around
them, both supernatural and human.
At the end of Stand By Me, Gordie LaChance
is finishing the last lines of his memoir,
inspired by the news of his childhood best
friend's death.
His office has dark wood paneling and a wall
of books around him, as well as a picture
window looking out onto the front yard.
In It: Chapter Two, Bill's office is a replica
of Gordie's, albeit with a sleek laptop rather
than a clunky 1980s home computer.
And like in Stand By Me, Bill is working on
his own book about childhood.
1986's Stand By Me was the film that gave
Stephen King a reputation for more than his
horror stories.
It also helped catapult young actors River
Phoenix, Wil Wheaton, Corey Feldman, and Jerry
O'Connell to stardom in film and television.
Phoenix's promising career was sadly cut short
in its prime when he died of an overdose in
1993.
In It: Chapter Two, the film adaptation of
Bill's horror novel is being helmed by Peter
Bogdanovich, who directed River Phoenix in
one of his final movies, The Thing Called
Love.
As it turns out, cinema legend Bogdanovich
is actually a friend of It director Andy Muschietti
and asked for the cameo personally.
The connection to Stand By Me and River Phoenix
is the poetry of coincidence, but still brings
a melancholy touch to It: Chapter Two for
fans who remember him fondly.
In Stephen King's epic gunslinger fantasy
series The Dark Tower, roses have a special
significance.
Their appearance often indicates a nearby
portal to parallel universes, and certain
roses are powerful enough to enchant and heal
with their mystical properties.
One in particular, known simply as The Rose,
is found in an abandoned lot in New York City
at the corner of Second and Forty-Sixth street.
Rose symbolism appears frequently in King's
works, including It.
In It: Chapter Two, Bill finds his old bike
Silver at the vintage shop Secondhand Rose,
which is a sly reference to things that were
once beautiful and important but are now merely
taking up shelf space in a small-town store.
In the book, the store has the full name Secondhand
Rose, Secondhand Clothes, and Bill buys his
Schwinn for $20.
In Chapter Two the proprietor, played by Stephen
King himself, charges Bill $300.
When the older Losers go back to the house
on Neibolt Street in Chapter Two, a 1950s-era
Amana fridge that was first seen in Chapter
One makes another appearance.
Inside the fridge they find Stanley's decapitated
head, along with a host of other nastiness.
In the novel It, that fridge played heavily
in a number of disturbing scenes that have
never made it to the screen due to their graphic
nature.
Most notably, the fridge in the junkyard is
where Pennywise victim and school bully Patrick
Hockstetter would trap animals and wait for
them to suffocate to death.
It's also the site where Patrick met his untimely
end in a swarm of flying leeches.
"Mother f------------"
In It: Chapter Two, the civic pride expressed
by the phrase "I Heart Derry" takes a sinister
turn.
In Chapter One, the message can be seen printed
on one of Pennywise's red balloons, a reference
to a horrific hate crime in the book that
hadn't been put to screen until Chapter Two.
After winning an "I Heart Derry" cap at the
Canal Days carnival, Adrian Mellon and his
boyfriend begin walking home, talking about
their future.
On the way, they are set upon by a group of
homophobic bullies who viciously beat the
couple, throwing Adrian's body over the bridge
and into the speeding current below, where
Pennywise proceeds to eat him.
King based Adrian Mellon's storyline on a
real-life hate crime that played out exactly
as he wrote it.
Minus the cannibal clown, at least.
It: Chapter Two is the first adaptation to
put these horrifying events on screen, putting
the previous "I Heart Derry" reference into
its proper context.
In every It adaptation, and as per the book,
the local cinema plays a huge part in the
Losers' story.
During the summer it's a safe space for kids
to escape from Henry Bowers and his gang of
bullies.
It's also the place where many of Pennywise's
tormenting monsters take shape for the Losers,
like Ritchie's Wolf Man.
But in It: Chapter Two, the movie theater
is boarded up and closed down, with only movie
posters to indicate when the shuttering happened.
We get a closer look when Richie visits the
place during his search for a token, and one
of the posters is 1998's Tom Hanks and Meg
Ryan rom-com You've Got Mail, which implies
that the theater closed its doors sometime
before the turn of the century.
But more ominously, there are two rips in
the poster that spell out a scraggly "IT."
Turns out, that's a sneaky bit of foreshadowing,
since Richie is about to have his own run-in
with Pennywise.
"Beep beep, Richie"
In the novel, the Bradley Gang were a group
of gangsters who made Derry a pit-stop during
Prohibition.
One day, in a strange series of events that
points to Pennywise's evil machinations, the
Bradley Gang were massacred by townsfolk in
one fell swoop.
The event went down as historic legend, and
both It: Chapter One and Chapter Two feature
a mural in Derry commemorating the gruesome
event.
What Chapter Two adds to the story is that
Ben actually found the Bradley Gang's bunker
and reinforced it so the Losers could use
it as a hideout from Henry Bowers and the
other bullies.
This is why Ben finds a bunch of rusted old
padlocks and chains down there.
The Bradley Gang had already made this a secure
hiding spot, and the hole was waiting in the
woods for the Losers to find and adopt it
as their own.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.